Hi guys good evening how are you guys?
can you hear me?
can you hear me guys?
ok
can you hear the background noise from the back?
because it is very loud here
ok
ok i guess the noise cancellation is at work
so lets start in a while guys
before that, any of you who attended the last loop engineering session
which was conducted by Rupinder
anyone?
so I was saying yes Aman
how was it?
how was your experience?
it was Rupinder's first class
so just wanted to take some feedback
did you understand what loop engineering is?
we cleared some fundamentals
it was good? ok
so Rupinder is basically our newest joinee
he joined a month ago
and he is basically a researcher who is working with us
but at the same time he is interested in teaching
means he likes teaching
so we discussed that there is this new topic
anyways you are researching on this
would you like to take a session?
so he was interested and that's how we planned the session
so if you guys liked his teaching style
then going forward
Rupinder will take a session on the new topics
ok
so basically we will teach you guys
there are 3 people now
Rupinder will be the fourth guy
so yeah
that was about the feedback
let's wait a little more
because there are very few people now
do you have any questions from your side?
if you have any doubts then ask
then when the session starts I won't be able to answer
thank you
will tool, MCP and multi agent related evals be covered?
yes Saurav
there will be a dedicated class on agents evaluation
so there
we will discuss all these things
Mahesh Singh, Google IO was good sir you missed it
ok did you attend?
how was it?
Varun is saying no audio
Varun most likely this is from your end
because he is making others hear
ok
let's see what's going on in the announcement video
for now this year's IO is missed
no problem
sir what if we need to evaluate JSON generated by LLM
where keys can be compared with ground truth
with semantic meaning but value should be exact
should I use LLM as a judge with deep eval to evaluate
where keys can be compared with ground truth
with semantic meaning but values should be exact
should I use LLM as a judge with deep eval to evaluate
but LLM as a judge can match exact values
I think I will have to use some mixture
can we please have the AI system design course on priority
all the interviews are focused on system design guardrails and evals
let's finish these courses
currently there are 3 courses in pipeline
first is LLM evals
then LLM ops
and third is context engineering
it is not live but working on it
so these 3 are finished
so let's finish this course
after these 3 we will have to teach the next courses
which are very high priority
one of them is AI system design
second is AI security and guardrails
so hopefully we can reach there in 2-3 months
so let's start the class
so we are recording the context engineering course offline
we are not conducting live sessions around it
like we normally record
a self-learning course
self-based course
it is recording in that way
it is 50% done
it will take one more month
after that it will be released for you
so let's assume that you will get to see the course around 1st September
so LLM eval will have only one class every week
no Sumit, it is not like that
it is a little circumstantial
last week we had to do a loop engineering class
and this week again I have some availability issue
but I will try to cover 2 classes per week
next week onwards we will have 2 classes
so let's start this session
we will keep the same structure
first let's revise what we have read so far
because last class was done a week ago
and then we will discuss what we are going to cover in today's class
so quick recap
what we have covered in this course so far
we have
why
what is happening
just one second guys
my tab is not working properly
just one second
here it is not picking up
I will try another port
now it will work
just one second
yeah now it is working
sorry
so yeah guys quick recap
what we have covered so far
I know you guys think why I always start doing recap before every session
I always do recap because as a teacher
whenever I start a session after doing recap
I get into the flow
I get to know what we have studied so far
what we have to study today
how to connect
I get to know all that
so just bear with me even if you know what we have covered so far
I will just give you a quick recap
we started with why do we need LLMEval
then we discussed what exactly are LLMEvals
here we discussed a very important thing
that there are two types of LLMEvals
one is model evals
and the other is application evals
you know right
model evals means evals which we use specifically to evaluate LLMs
and application evals which we use to evaluate LLM based applications
and I told you that the main focus of this course will be application evals
here you will learn about the evaluation of the rag and agent
after that we discussed an eval pipeline
basically how evals work
then we discussed an interesting point
why do we need multiple eval pipelines
and in the last video we covered an important topic of online evals
that once you do the evaluation of your application
you deploy it
then how to evaluate it even after deployment
we discussed this in the last video
so in a way I can say that we have discussed an overview of this course
now we will go into specifics
we will cover what we have studied in detail
like the main goal of today's video is that we will cover model evals
model evals means evals which you use to test LLM capabilities
so we will start working on model evals from today
it will not be covered in a single lecture
I am trying to cover this in two lectures
let's start the session
first of all, as we have a flow in campusX
why, what, how
let's move ahead
first of all let's discuss
why do we need model evals
in fact we will not ask this question
we will ask this question
why AI engineers need model evals
because I have told you that we are studying this course from the perspective of AI engineers
so rather than discussing what is the need of model evals
we already know what is the need of model evals
what is the need of model evals
model evals exist so that we can measure
the capabilities of our LLMs
why is it important to measure these capabilities
because if you don't measure then how will you improve
you might have heard that famous line
if you can't measure you can't improve
so model evals basically give us mechanisms
with the help of which we can evaluate the capabilities of multiple types of LLMs
so that is why model evals exist in general
but we will talk from the perspective of AI engineers
if I am an AI engineer
my day to day work is to make LLM based applications
then why is model evals important for me
I can understand that model evals are necessary for Frontier Labs
because on the basis of that Frontier Labs understands what improvement they have to do
where they have made a mistake, how to shape their training
but as an AI engineer why is model evals important for me
we will discuss this
so till now whatever discussion we had
in this entire playlist, in this entire course
was that how to evaluate LLM based applications
we were talking about how to evaluate retriever in a rag application
how to evaluate generator
how to evaluate the entire pipeline
how to evaluate the entire application
but remember that in this entire discussion
we never discussed that
how to use LLM to run this rag application
which will be the brain of this application
how to evaluate it, how to select it
think about it
suppose you are thinking of making a rag application for your company
so obviously the first question will be
which LLM will you use
will you use OpenAI LLM
or will you use Claude LLM
it is a simple question, think about it
you have two options, OpenAI and Claude
now you can't say in a professional setting
that whatever you use, both are good
you can't talk like this
in a team meeting you will have to come with concrete pointers
why you should opt OpenAI LLM or why you should opt Claude LLM
and to answer this question you need Model evals
on the basis of Model evals you can say in a concrete way
that these are the pointers, these are the capabilities
which are necessary for our application
and in that capability this particular LLM is scoring more
and that is why we should choose this particular LLM over the competitor
so the first reason is to read Model evals
as an AI engineer that you can easily compare two or more different models
and you can choose one for your application
so this is reason number one
reason number two is that if Model evals will be in the picture
then you can track that the new models that are coming
are they really improving or not
think about it, your rag application is deployed
you have applied Claude's Opus 4.8
everything is working properly
now Claude's fable has come
now your manager is asking you to do some research
and tell us whether we should deploy fable or let it stay on Opus
now how will you understand this
how would you know this as a fact that fable is better
again the answer is Model evals
so you will get those numbers through Model evals
on the basis of which you can justify whether a new model is better than the previous model
point number three
Model evals is the only way on which you can tell
that your model that you have deployed or are going to deploy is safe
Model evals tells you how much your LLM is hallucinating
how safe it is to use
whether it can be jailbreak
all these things are told by Model evals
and the last point is
on the basis of Model evals you can make a very important decision
that you should host your own LLM
deploy it or use the existing APIs
how will you decide that you should go with a proprietary LLM like Claude
or you should go with an open source LLM like DeepSeq
both have their own advantages
it may be that Claude is getting more expensive
DeepSeq may be getting cheaper
but it may be that Claude is more powerful
or better in multiple capabilities
and DeepSeq may not match
so how would you decide that should I go for a proprietary LLM
should I use the APIs directly
or should I pull an open source model from the hugging face
and make your own APIs on your company's server
and make your own APIs and make your own application
again this comparison is facilitated using Model evals
so in Naxal you are without Model evals
you are basically blind
if you want to see what kind of model is there
and if you want to compare two models
the only option that you have is Model evals
so in that sense as an AI engineer this topic is very very important
and that is why we will cover this topic well
so at this point is the explanation clear
why do we need Model evals
it was simple, you must have known most of the things
tell the rest of the people guys
if you have any questions you can ask
ok
yes and same goes with embedding models as well
I just said LLM but you can include embedding models as well
ok now let's do one thing
we understood that model evals are necessary
now let's properly formally discuss what are model evals
ok so far we have only discussed that
model eval is basically a way to evaluate your LLMs
we will discuss that more formally in this section
so here it is written
and operational characteristics under controlled conditions
ok so that definition has been expanded a little
but in nutshell it is still the same
that model eval is a process with which you can test any LLM
its capabilities, its behavior can be tested
ok now if we talk on a technical level
that what exactly happens in a model eval
so whenever you talk about any type of model eval
there are four things
every model eval follows four steps
first of all you decide what capabilities of LLM you want to test
LLMs are general purpose models
right, they can do a lot of things
they have a lot of capabilities
so there is no single model eval that can test every capability
it's not like humans have IQ
you can tell a lot about a human with a single number
unfortunately LLMs don't have that
every LLMs have a different model eval for every capability
so the first thing that you have in model eval is
that you decide what capability you want to test
do you want to test its reasoning capability
or its coding capability
or do you want to see how safe it is to use
or do you want to test its instruction following capability
so the first thing that you do is you decide the capability that you want to test
ok, after that what you do
you bring a test to test that capability
ok, you bring a test or a mechanism
with which you will test that capability
ok, I will talk about this a little later
but the second step is that you bring a test
third is that you run that model on that test
basically that model gives the exam
and during the exam you fix some things
like which prompt you will send, what kind of conditions will be there
you fix all these things so that you can repeat it further
if you are testing multiple models then all the models should get one kind of condition
so the third is you run the model under fixed protocol
and the fourth thing is once the test is done you score and interpret
it is simple
so if we talk about the four steps then you first decide which capability to test
to test that capability you bring a test for the exam
then you run that test in a controlled environment
and you publish or interpret the score
so these are the four steps
let's talk about the second important step
where we said that we bring a test
there are two types of tests in model evals
see here I have written it down
the first test is called benchmark
maybe you have heard its name
there are very famous benchmarks
what are the benchmarks?
benchmarks are basically standardized shared tests
so if there is a test like MMLU or SWI bench
because everyone runs the same test
it is great for comparing models on common ground
so benchmark is a type of test
benchmark is like a standardized test
it is basically the same for all the models
and you can openly compare the numbers of the two models
it is like a standardized thing
everyone recognizes it and everyone uses it
and the second thing is that
rather than testing an LLM on the benchmark
you make your own evaluation sets
see here it is written
this is a very important point
understand this
I also said an important point
that model evals are of two types
one is benchmarks
which are basically standardized tests
which test specific capabilities
like the capability of maths
or the capability of reasoning
or the capability of instruction following
and the second thing is that
you sometimes run custom evaluations on your model
because you have to know that
how your given LLM will perform on your application
now obviously you might have a question in your mind
that if I am getting answers from the benchmark
like how good is the math, reasoning, coding
then why do I need to run my own custom evaluation
I will answer this question
let's take a small scenario
if you remember we discussed in the first session
that we had made a system for Zomato
which reads the incoming email content
and tells that the mail should be routed to billing
or there were two other categories
like billing, technical and refund
let's remove these three categories
I don't remember the last session
let's remove this
so basically you have to make this application
now to make this application
you have two model choices
model A is a proper big LLM
it is written here
big, top of the leaderboard but expensive
here you have to spend roughly 15 dollars
on using 1 million tokens
and second you have the option of a second model
which is a small model and obviously cheap
here you have to spend 50 cents on using 1 million tokens
and if we talk about public benchmarks
then it is mid of the table
whereas model A is top of the table
so you can think of it as a Claude or Opus type model
and you can think of it as a minmax or quen
or a model with less than a billion parameters
so what does common sense say here
why are you thinking so much?
deploy model A directly
model A will give good results
but understand one thing here
if you directly apply model A on Zomato scale
then this expense can increase a lot
so here clearly if you talk about benchmarks
then on every benchmark model A will be better than model B
right?
it will be good in maths, coding, language generation
it will be good in everything
so here the obvious answer is that model A should be used
but what will you do here?
you will simply do a small task
you will make your own data set
where you will bring 500 past emails from 200
and you will label them too
whether that email is technical or billing or refund
basically you are making a golden data set
and you will give this golden data set to model A
and model B too
and you will get the results
so after getting the results we came to know that
classification accuracy of model A is 94%
and model B is obviously less
but surprisingly this task is not that difficult
so the second model is also scoring 91%
what is urgency accuracy?
reading the mail content and reading how urgently the user should reply
so model A is also giving 88% of the email
and it is giving 87%
again there is not much difference
and to process 1000 emails
we are taking 6 dollars
here less than 0.21 dollars
and talking about latency
since this is a big model
it is taking 4.1 seconds whereas
this one is taking just 0.9 seconds to serve a request
now tell me based on this table
logically which model would you choose?
would you go for model A which is a bigger powerful model or B?
it is very very simple and very very straight forward
that you will say that even though model A is very powerful
and is very good in comparison with model B
but for our task model B is a much better value proposition
because we are not using too much accuracy
but we are saving a lot of money and latency
so we will go with model B
now think about it
if we would have depended on only benchmarks
would we have reached this conclusion?
quickly tell me
if we had only the option of benchmarks
if we would have done model evaluation only through benchmarks
would we have reached the conclusion that model B is better?
no, in every benchmark model A beats model B
but since we have done a custom eval on our data
then we have come to know that model B is better for our work
so I guess you are understanding what is model eval?
it is a process of testing the capabilities of a model
but you can test it in two ways
either you run standardized benchmarks
through which you will get to know the generic capabilities of the model
or you can run specific custom evals
according to your application and data
so that you can get to know which model is more suitable for your kind of work
so is this entire discussion clear?
what are model evals and what are their types?
now what we will do is
we will spend the entire discussion on benchmarks
because what are benchmarks?
how do benchmarks work?
what is the evaluation process of benchmarks?
what are the famous benchmarks?
all this is important to know
how to read benchmarks
and that is why we will spend the entire session on benchmarks
so basically the name of today's session will be LLM Benchmarking
and then the next session will be
where we will learn how do you run custom model evals
how can you run your evals on a given LLM?
so we are dividing the whole thing into two parts
this is today's session
this will be the next session
so is the discussion clear so far?
are you understanding the things so far?
ok, any questions so far?
I will wait for one minute
if you have any questions so far then ask
ok
Naina is asking
benchmark is just a data set
not really
benchmark is more than a data set
we will discuss it now
we will discuss benchmarks in detail in a little while
today's topic is benchmarks so we will cover it well
any other question?
ok
so look
so before discussing benchmarks
we should first discuss capabilities
what capabilities can be found in an LLM
so we discussed earlier that
LLMs are like general purpose
the biggest quality of LLMs is that they are general purpose
you can see that in LLMs
we have a general purpose
so we will discuss about that
so the biggest quality of LLMs is that they are general purpose
you can do different types of work with them
you can do text generation
you can do sentiment analysis
you can do summarization
you can do parts of speech tagging
so it can do a lot of things
there are a lot of capabilities in it
and who tests those capabilities?
benchmarks
but before reading benchmarks
you should know
what are the core capabilities
in LLMs
mostly speaking
what are the core capabilities
so in total there are
8 core capabilities
which everyone has agreed
and most of the benchmarks
which you will see in the future
you will see them in these 8 categories
so next what we are going to do in 10 minutes
all the core capabilities
we are discussing them once
we have discussed this in the past
but now we will discuss in more detail
there is a disclaimer
this discussion
will be for next 10 minutes
this is a bit text heavy
there is a lot of text on the screen
and I will read a lot
because whatever explanation is written here
so let's start
the first core capability
is
knowledge and reasoning
we have clubbed these two together
because
both of them work together
so you must know the meaning of both
as it is written here
that in this domain
two things come
first, how much factual knowledge
does our LLM have
which he learned during training
and second
is he able to connect
all that factual knowledge
or is he able to connect dots
or not
we measure these two things
what exactly are discussed here
what are measured
first, we measure
how much is the factual
recall of our LLM on different subjects
like biology
physics, chemistry, history
infact there is a
benchmark called MMLU
which on 57 subjects
evaluates the model
so
whatever your
field of knowledge is
you test on all of them
that
if your LLM is able to answer
its basic questions
or not
this is the first thing that is tested
in the capability of knowledge
second is multi-step logical reasoning
here you test
that if your model
is able to connect multiple facts
in the right sequence
to a conclusion or not
let me give you a simple example
I asked this question
that
summarize the whole evolution
of human evolution
from big bang
till now
analyze that whole thing
and tell me why today's society
is like this
so here you see
multiple aspects
we are testing
our model
first we are checking its factual knowledge
so we are checking
what events have happened
in which order
and then we are connecting all of them
and telling them
what effect that whole thing had on today's society
so this is a proper task
where its knowledge is being tested
and its reasoning is also being tested
so we check this kind of thing
so this is the first capability
knowledge and reasoning
second capability is
before that
why frontier labs
focus on this particular capability
I have written that here
if your model is
scoring well in knowledge
and reasoning
then it simply means
how intelligent your model is
and that is why frontier labs
care about this a lot
so here whatever benchmarks you read
every model wants to score well
because on the basis of this
it is judged that how intelligent
so that is why this one is important
in real world
where is this capability used
its very simple
if you are making a research chatbot
whose job is to analyze
research papers
and conduct new research
there knowledge plus reasoning
both are checked
if you are analyzing complex customer questions
here I am not really sure
if its used that much or not
but its written
in really accurate documents
you uploaded a paper on machine learning
from there you are asking questions
so reasoning is very tested
if you are making a chatbot
which is helping professionals
in their field
like a lawyer helping in law
or a teacher helping in teaching a subject
then again this capability is tested
so this is the first
very important capability
as I said, this is how a model is
decided how intelligent it is
the second capability is coding
and software engineering
if you ask this from my point of view
then its most important
from the point of
economics
means from here
any model provider
any frontier lab can earn a lot of money
I guess you are getting it
cursor valuation is 60 billion dollars
all because of this capability
because LLMs can code
can do tasks of software engineering
and in today's date software development
is a big big field
if a model is doing well there
then you are basically creating a lot of value
for a lot of enterprises
so in that sense this capability is very important
here what you measure
that can your model
write such code
which really works
this is the basic question
apart from this you check
that can you do real software engineering
tasks or not
can you edit code based on this
which are major
tasks of software engineering
what comes here is exactly written
can your model
generate functional code
you gave an english sentence
that give me such a function
in python
so is it able to create that function
is it able to generate test cases
is it able to improve
the code based on error in test cases
all this comes here
second capability
which is tested here is
can you go to existing code bases
and do bug fixing or not
this is also very important
then can you do multi file
long horizon engineering
tasks or not
you were given a code base
and you were asked to refactor
the code base on one aspect
so is it able to do this or not
this is the capability
can you run multiple commands
for example you were asked to
install some packages
configure servers
and set up some environment
so is it able to do all this
lastly can you do API and
function calling or not
all these capabilities are tested
here
so what is the real world relevance
whenever you are making any
AI coding agent
which are many in the world
then you have to use this capability
so in that sense this capability
is super important
third capability is mathematics
again
here you simply measure
whether your model
is able to do accurate symbolic
and numerical reasoning or not
basically you can consider maths
as a form of reasoning
maths is a form of reasoning
that you are getting to a solution
step by step
so it is a form of reasoning
so there are more applications in the real world
so what all you test here
first of all you test
whether your model
can solve grade school level mathematics
7th, 8th class mathematics
problem solving or not
whether your model
is able to solve competition level problem solving
like the problems asked in Olympiarts
where a little creative thinking is required
whether it is able to solve problems of that level
whether it is able to solve problems
of undergraduate level or not
and lastly, whether
it is able to do research level mathematical reasoning or not
some problems which are open ended
and which do not have solutions
whether you are able to reach there or not
all these capabilities are available in mathematics
and again this is very important
because there are many fields
if you touch them while making applications
like scientific computing
financial modeling, engineering simulations
data analysis
if you are making applications for all these fields
then your mathematics capability
will be useful
so again this is a very important capability
on which many benchmarks have been made
because it is super important to test it
4th one is long context
context I guess you know
simple meaning of context
is that while doing
a particular answer
your model is able to see how much information
and it is limited
right, nowadays
models have a limit of 1 million
context window is there
but in that also
is it able to use everything or not
that is a big question, see it is written here
this domain measures
whether a model can effectively
use information from very long inputs
sometimes containing hundreds
of thousands of tokens
so here what all measures are done
that whether you are able to extract
a small fact in a very long context
or not
whether you
from a very big
document
can you fetch the details of
one person or entity
whether you are able to summarize
a very big context or not
and lastly if you are
working like a coding agent
then whether you are able to maintain
the whole context of a very big code base
you judge things like this here
so
for frontier labs again this is a very
important capability
because models say
that their context window is
128k tokens, 200k tokens
1 million tokens
but actually what happens is
as your chat gets bigger
you will notice that
the capability of retaining the context
diminishes, decreases
and the quality of chat over time
gets worse
so by testing this particular capability
you will understand that which model
can actually work well in big context
so these metrics are very important
and this is applicable everywhere
if you make any kind of LLM based
application, long context
will become a very important capability
to measure, from that you will know
how long the context is being handled
from your model
ok
fifth one is vision and multimodal
I am summarizing it a little
you will get this document, you read it
everything is written in detail
here you simply surpass the text
and you go to the vision domain
and the idea is that
is your model able to understand vision
images, videos
or not
and again it is very important because we live in a multimodal world
and it doesn't work only with text
in today's world
we are asking by turning on the video
that tell me, in the fridge
what can be made of this
or in a library we are asking for a particular book
so we are living in a multimodal world
so multimodal capabilities
should also have benchmarks
so this is also a very important capability
to measure
ok
sixth one is agentic and tool use
again a capability
which is getting more important
the field of agentic
AI
has emerged from here
that you don't need only LLMs
which can only print text
you need LLMs which
can do something
and to do that you have to
match the text
so basically here you have to
test that your model
is able to use tools
effectively
is it able to do web browsing
is it able to do structured tool calling
is it able to interact with APIs
is it able to use desktop and computers
so you evaluate
such things here
here you get such benchmarks
again for frontier labs it is important
because going forward
you are already seeing many agentic applications
so to make such
agentic applications
you need a reliable model
which can do agentic tasks
and whether it is able to do it or not
it tells you the same benchmarks
the same capability
the seventh one is safety and alignment
again very straight forward
here you just measure
that your model
can be trusted to behave responsibly
so here you
check such things
that is not generating harmful content
like an adversarial attack
that
it is not easy to do adversarial attacks
is it truthful
or is it a trap
you must have seen chat gpt
if you present an idea it immediately
starts praising you that yes this is the best idea in the world
it should not be like that
ideally a model should be truthful
in my personal experience
I have always seen that Claude is much more truthful
he sometimes praises me
Claude is like
no, what you said has flaws
so this is an important thing
then recently
such models and benchmarks are coming
which check
whether you have
cyber security related skills in LLM
can your model do cryptography
or reverse engineering
or digital forensics
this Claude fable
was a model
which was very strong in cyber security
and it has removed many vulnerabilities
in existing software
so how will you test
whether this model has cyber security related skills
it has different benchmarks
so safety
is a very important thing
for frontier AI labs
because government pressurizes them
that your model should be safe
along with that
there is a big reputational concern for them
if any minor incident happens
then their business can be ruined
so in this sense
it is very important to track
this capability
for frontier AI labs
and the last thing is
it is kind of underrated
but instruction following is very important
this is also a very important capability
here you measure
whether the model did
exactly what you told the user
to do
or not
so I asked the user to give me answers in bullet list
so he did
or not
I asked for answers in less than 200 words
I asked for friendly answers
whether the model is accepting all these things
it is also very important to test
because it directly translates into user feedback
the model will not listen to us
the user will be unhappy
the product will leave
and will go to another company
so in that sense
this capability is also very important
that whether the user is following
what the user is telling
and if
ambiguous instructions are coming
from the user then whether the
model clarifying questions is asking
these things are tested here
so this is a very detailed document
I will give you this tomorrow
read it once by yourself
it will be boring to read it line by line
so I compressed it in 10 minutes
but in nutshell these are the 8 capabilities
which are focused on every frontier lab
and all the benchmarks
that you will read in the future
they target one of these capabilities
if I summarize
so we read knowledge and reasoning
coding
mathematics
long context
vision and multimodal
agentic and tool use
safety and alignment
and lastly instruction following
these are the 8
core capabilities
so let me know
if you have any doubt
or any question
is it clear
whatever you have read till now
I know it was very straight forward
it is basically theory
see
I
because I am a teacher
I can understand
I feel that
some of you
must be thinking
this is the fourth session
in this course
and we are mostly reading theory
we are getting bored
and is it even important
trust me
I will tell you in my experience
that in my life
whenever I have read
complex topics
whenever I have covered theory
in overview mode
so in the practical part
people have enjoyed reading it
because they have seen
things from multiple perspectives
if I teach you on day 1
how to make golden data sets
or what are the metrics
so your mind
will learn as much as I will teach you
but now you will observe
within two sessions
when we will do practical things
so you will understand
what you will read
and you will be able to ask more questions
explore more
this is the difference
and that is why I have opted for this method
where initially I am covering a lot of theory
and I am trying to make sure it is not boring
but yes I am covering a lot of theory
in comparison to some other class
or company or youtube channel
so from day 1 you are taught practical things
and this is a conscious choice from my side
now if you abuse me for this
then do it
but I think this works
I have seen this in the past with multiple courses
MLops or
even deep learning
so there I spent a good amount of time on theory
which eventually
translated into good practical
experience
so you have to trust me on this
I am basically
trying to do my job
that's it
so yeah, let's stop for a minute
and wait for any questions
if anyone has any in their mind
and then we will move forward
in the session
so
is there any question in someone's mind
yeah, it seems like
there can be two reasons
either everyone is agreeing or everyone is of my age
obviously those of my age
will resonate with me because
it happens
in thirties
you think a little different from twenties
question is
sir, benchmark questions
everyone uses the same
or only the metrics are the same
you will understand everything in a minute
I guess you are getting the question in your mind
what are benchmarks
in the next 15 minutes
you will understand everything
what are benchmarks
don't worry, ask this question after a while
if it's not clear
don't you think
to meet
these benchmarks
is a very costly process
we will discuss that too
I have a small practical code
I will discuss a little
how much money is spent
when you run benchmarks
on a particular LLM
so, it's okay
mostly it seems like questions
are related to the content
so it's okay
so,
so far
the discussion
what we have done
what is the flow of the class
first we studied
why model evals are necessary
then we formally studied
what are model evals
we came to know that there are two types of
model evals, one is standardized
benchmarks and the other is custom evals
and today's session is
all about benchmarks
but I told you that before reading
benchmarks
you should know what core capabilities
exist, so we studied that
there are 8 core capabilities
so we studied till here
now we are fully equipped
fully prepared to actually study
what are benchmarks
so now in the next 10-15 minutes
we are going to spend on this topic
and trust me, I will teach in overview mode
mostly you will understand things
so in simple words
if someone asks you what are
LLM benchmarks
it's a very famous term, all day long
left, right, center, any model comes
benchmarks are thrown on you
how much this model scored on
sui bench
how much
it scored on rkgi
how much different models
are scoring on different benchmarks
on that basis you get to see youtube videos
so what is a benchmark
so in simple words
a benchmark is basically
a standardized test
used to measure
a particular model capability
in simple words
a benchmark is nothing but a
standardized test
which tests
a specific model capability
this is the simple definition
ok
now
in a benchmark
there are 4 things
you will get 4 things
first thing is
a data set
slash task
second is
run config
or run configuration
third is
scoring
and fourth is
aggregation
these are 4 things, see it is written here
first data set, run configuration
scoring method
and aggregation method
these are 4 things in a benchmark
ok, so what we do
we take an example benchmark
and on that basis
we will understand what these 4 things are
so we will talk about a benchmark
the name of this benchmark
is
gsm8k
has anyone heard of this name
if you have heard then tell me
which capability is used to test
gsm8k
this is an old
benchmark
it came in 2020-2021
now it is not used that much
its full form is
grade school mathematics
gsm
8k means
that this particular benchmark
data set has around 8k
rows
so we will understand
from this benchmark lens
what all things
are there in any benchmark
so first of all
let's discuss what is gsm8k's data set
and what is the task
so see it is written here
the data set is the question
plus the answer key
whenever there is a data set in a benchmark
there are 2 things in it
questions are there and answers are also there
its like a golden data set
like in gsm8k
there are math questions
and its solution is also there
like here is a sample question
Natalia sold clips
to 48 friends
in April
and then she sold half
as many clips in May
how many clips did she
sell all together
in April 48
and in May
24 because half
you just have to add them
and the answer is 72
so basically these are very simple
mathematical questions
grade school maths
maths of 6th, 7th, 8th
these are the data sets
how many questions are there
8000 data sets, infact you can google
this you can also get on google
you simply have to search
gsm8k
and you will get it in 2-3 places
you will get it on hugging face
you will also get it on kaggle
here is the
repository of this particular data set
here you go to files and versions
go to main
here is your data set
here you see exactly
here is the question and here is the answer
and how many questions and answers are there
around 8000-8500
so this is the data set
which is used in gsm8k
similarly
in gmlu
there is your own data set
there is your own data set of some other benchmark
every benchmark
has a data set
which has both questions and answers
and you are told a task
here the task is
when your model is given a simple
grade school mathematics problem
then you have to generate the answer
this is the task
so you have come this far, you understood
this is the first component
second component is
every benchmark gives you some guidelines
that when you use
that benchmark for evaluation
then what typical settings
you have to keep while doing
the evaluation
it is not like you have
run one model in a particular setting
and run the other model in some other setting
when you are doing
the evaluations of two models
then while running both the models
all the settings should be
the same
so the settings are told in the run configuration
so there are
three parts
first is prompt
second is decoding
and sampling configuration
and third is your scoring strategy
and environment
I will tell you about all three
so in prompt construction
you are told that
when you write the prompt
and send it
from here
you will pick a question
and send it to the model
the model will give the answer
but along with sending this question
you also send a system prompt
so how you write
the system prompt
that also matters
if the prompt is different then one model will give different result
and the other will give different result
I guess you understood
so in prompt construction
you define that your system prompt
will be zero shot
or few shot
it's simple meaning is
when you are sending this
question to your LLM
by taking out the answer
then along with that
you want to show some solved examples
and send it
or you want to give it without any example
so this is called
zero shot
zero shot means you simply
picked up the question and gave it
and
few shot means
you solved some questions like this
in the prompt
and then at last you sent a question
that you solved these questions like this
and now solve this question
and tell me
so in prompt construction
in benchmark you are told
that you want to keep zero shot
or few shot
now if you talk about GSM 8k
GSM 8k
uses few shot strategy
as written here
that GSM 8k
is classically reported
eight shot, meaning whenever you
send a question to LLM
then you show it first
eight solved examples
in system prompt
and then you send your question
obviously if you keep zero shot
then the performance of model will be bad
and if you keep few shots
then your performance will improve
so in GSM 8k
few shot is kept
second, are you allowing
chain of thought
or are you telling it to work directly
chain of thought, if you are allowing
then you are sending some kind of system prompt
that see this question
and try to solve it
step by step
like here the answer is also shown
Natalia sold 48
divided by 2
means 24 clips in may
Natalia sold 48 plus 24
clips all together
this is getting solved step by step and is reaching the answer
if you are not allowing chain of thought
and you are telling
to directly answer this
then chances of mistakes are more
so in GSM 8k also
chain of thought is allowed
again, here we are just talking
about the options available
while constructing the prompt
few shot, zero shot, chain of thought
or normal
after that
you see things
in your decoding and sampling configuration
you keep temperature value
around zero
because if you increase it more than zero
then creative answers start coming
and every time they start varying
so temperature is mostly around zero
for such benchmarks
then you set a max token
if you set a very less max token
then it can be
since chain of thought is triggered
and while thinking in the reach
the answer is over and model
was not able to generate the answer
versus if you have allowed too much tokens
then what can a very powerful model do
it can reason very strongly
so you specify max token
that I will give max token to model A
and max token to model B
it is not very less or very much
so this is the second setting
after that
this is a very interesting thing
that you
finalize the scoring strategy
what is scoring strategy
one scoring strategy is
pass at the rate 1
this means that you
show your model
one question
once, it gave the answer
now that answer will be either right or wrong
so this is called
pass at the rate 1
then comes your
pass at the rate k
what happens in this is that if you
did pass at the rate 5
then you will ask
one question 5 times
from the same model
and if he answered
at least once out of 5 times
then you will assume that model gave the right answer
so basically pass at the k is
a more lenient strategy
to evaluate your LLM
pass at the rate 1 is a more
strict strategy
so again you have to decide that you have to keep
pass at the rate 1 and pass at the rate k
will be the same during the evaluation
so in GSM 8k
actually, I don't remember
I have to see the paper
most likely pass at the rate 1 is used
but in some benchmarks
pass at the rate k can also be used
depending on how difficult
the question is
then you have one more
majority at the rate 8
majority at the rate k is basically
what happens in this is that
you ask the same question
from your model
it gives you
k different answers
the answer that comes most often
you assume
that answer
basically mode
the mode is mean-median mode
so you assume the mode as the answer
so whenever you
read in a benchmark
someone said that
in a particular benchmark
82% is scored by our model
so you should ask
that pass at the rate
1 strategy is used
pass at the rate k strategy is used
or majority at the rate k strategy is used
different scoring strategies
are used so you should know that
I hope you are understanding
then
do you want to allow
tools while evaluating the benchmark
or not
this is also told from the beginning
because if you allow tools
for example one tool is web search
if you allow web search
then it can
find the answer to a question
from the internet
or if you give it a coding
interpreter
then it will get all mathematical questions
through code and will get the answer
so should the tool be allowed
or not
this is also decided from the beginning
like obviously in GSM 8k benchmark
tools are not allowed
while evaluating the benchmarks
tools are also allowed
like your
sui bench
software engineering
in this you
get up issues
solve and test
so you have to fetch issues
for that you will need tools
so this is a benchmark
where you have to allow tools
I hope you are able to understand
that what we are talking about
what are the settings
that you have to apply in a benchmark
while performing the
evaluation, we are discussing this point
third
so yes
there are four things
what we covered from that
data set and task we covered
run configuration we discussed
third is
scoring
what is the scoring method
there are two important things in the scoring method
LLM's answer
LLM's answer is
what you did
this first question
along with a system prompt
in a defined setting you sent it to LLM
LLM gave you
an answer for that question
now that answer can be in any form
that answer can be
written the answer
is 72
this can also come
only 72 can also come
72 can also come
written
because that is LLM
it can give you any kind of output
so here you have to
work on extraction
so here
you will use structured LLM's
structured output
enforce
or you will use regx
to make sure
that you are able to extract the answer in the right format
first of all
the right answer is 72
so you need this number
nothing else
it emits
whatever it is you get the point
so extraction is the first step
during scoring and once you have extracted
then you have to do a comparison
so here it will be an exact comparison
because it is a maths test
so here 72 is equal to equal to 72
you will test it
any other number is wrong
and second
there is a benchmark
which
extracts open ended answers
this is a closed ended answer 72
but if it is open ended
then to evaluate it
you have to use LLM as a judge
I will give you an example
in the future
we will discuss a benchmark where answer is not
as straight forward as 72
so there is a proper
paragraph as answer
we have to evaluate that
so we use LLM as a judge there
so either the comparison
is done straight forward
or LLM as a judge
or through human
so this is the point of scoring
and the last is
aggregation
it is very simple
you have 8000 questions in the dataset
against every question
you get 1 or 0
that LLM has told the right answer
or not
so in aggregation stage
you simply aggregate
that I had 1000 questions
out of which 920 LLM has told the right answer
which basically means
that on our benchmark
this LLM scored 92%
that is how you do aggregation
now aggregation
most of the time is straight forward
like here
8500 times
we gave the question to LLM, we got the answer
scored it and saw
how many times he was right, how many times he was wrong
and on that basis we assigned a percentage
many times
there are some benchmarks
where aggregation is not as straight forward
for example MMLU
which basically
checks your general knowledge
across 57 subjects
so here
it is possible that you have to
publish different results
of every subject
like in biology
87%
in physics
91%
in economics
72%
now what you have to do is
again give an aggregate score
of overall MMLU
but here you cannot
divide all the percentages
by 57
because it is possible that
the biological questions are less in data
and the economic questions are more
so aggregation also has different strategies
so I have given you
an example of both
so in nutshell if we summarize this discussion
what is a benchmark
benchmark is basically
a standardized test
now in that test
there are multiple things
first you are told the task
what to measure
then you are given a data set
with questions and answers both
after that you are told
what will be the run configuration
in which conditions you will
execute this test
fourth is your
scoring mechanism and fifth is
your aggregation mechanism
and where are all these things written
where is all this told
it is very simple in the research paper
so most
of the benchmarks
which you are reading in today's date
they were originally
published as research papers
like if you search
GSM 8
paper
so this is the paper
in which for the first time
researchers brought this benchmark
in this benchmark
they discussed everything
which data set they used
what run configuration they used
what scoring mechanism they used
what aggregation mechanism they used
everything is mentioned in this paper
and then you get to see the same data set
on the internet similarly
you will get
MMLU paper
see
all this
is from the same paper
in this all the information is there
but the structure is the same
task will be there, data set will be there
run configuration will be there, scoring mechanism will be there
aggregation mechanism will be there
I am pretty sure it will be
of SWE bench
see
so each of these benchmarks were originally
a research paper which researchers brought
researchers have this work
they are actually studying
how can we test
any particular LLM's capability
so researchers from their field
bring benchmarks
from their field
and then those benchmarks get popular
their data sets get popular and then
they measure every new LLM
which comes in the market
so I was able to explain to you
what is the whole foundation of benchmarks
let me know
some people were asking questions about LLM
sorry what are benchmarks
so is the answer clear now
what all comes in it
is it clear
let me know
see
I have not intentionally
thrown many benchmarks on you
ideally I could have
thrown many names of benchmarks on you
I am not doing that
I will do this after some time
but first I want to give you an overall
idea of what benchmarks are
yes that's the
basic idea that
benchmark is a systematic test
standardized test
which we
run on a LLM
so everything is told to us
in the benchmark
what is the task
what is the data set
run configuration means in which setting
the test should run
how the scoring should be done
how the aggregation should be done
all this instruction is in the benchmark
it's a research paper
which has been published by researchers
I will wait
here for a couple of minutes
you can ask some questions
we will discuss more
don't worry
it's boring
you are reading theory
is it boring
how many questions in benchmarks
are different
like
in GSM 8k
there are 8000-8500 questions
in your SWE
bench
there is 163 github
issues
so different benchmarks have different questions
Sanjay
we will come to that point also
the question you are asking
what I have made last
the topic of today's session
is why benchmarks can be
misleading
I will answer your question
any other question at this point
please
move ahead
let's write yes
and move ahead
ok
so
now
let's discuss
we have a benchmark
a researcher
published a benchmark
a research paper
has been published
imagine that we are a frontier lab
we are a frontier lab
we are open AI
and we train our
LLMs
now we have
trained our new LLM
and we want to
test our
LLM
on this new benchmark
so now I will tell you
the exact process
how to use
a benchmark
to do a model evaluation
step by step
we have already discussed this
let's discuss it step by step
so what are we doing
we are a model provider
we are a frontier lab
we have a new LLM
let's say campus x
v1
and there is a benchmark
gsm 8k
which tests
mathematical capabilities
so what we have to do
we have to test our LLM
with the help of this benchmark
let's see how to do it step by step
so simply put
model evaluation on a benchmark
is basically a loop
it's basically a loop
you run a loop
where your
benchmark data set
every question becomes a row
so what we do is
simply put
we
pick up a question
and send it to our LLM
ok
and in that process we
exactly define the prompt
as we have been told in the benchmark
we keep the settings exactly as we have been told in the benchmark
and we send it
to our LLM
LLM gives us the answer
we have the actual answer
we compare it with the actual answer
we score according to the scoring mechanism
and how many times do we do this
we do it as many rows as we have in this data set
that many times
and after doing that many times
we aggregate all the scores
and there is a strategy of aggregation
which again tells us about the benchmark
so basically we are following the research paper
here it is written step by step
first of all load the item
in this particular
scenario load the first question
item means first question
ok
so here we run this loop
and if it runs for the first time then the first question is loaded
after that build the prompt
inject few short
examples if you want to do few short
apply the chat template
which you have to write separately
add instructions
now you have the exact string
which you want to send to the model
so in this step we have done exactly this
build prompt
here we have sent our item as in our question
few short 8 means we have
sent 8 examples here
now we have sent the entire chat template
so our prompt is ready
after that call the model
with the pinned decoding
config here you set the temperature
set the max token
you do all this in this step
so what you did is call model.generate
if you are doing it in lan chain then you will call invoke
your prompt which you
made in the previous steps you sent
set the temperature value
set the max token and
set any stopping criteria that
you want to avoid any problem
after that you capture the raw output
basically whatever
model sent you
you pull it
and
you extract the answer
from it
now it said the answer is 72
so you will extract only 72
and you will keep it
somewhere
after that what you will do is
basically this step is the extract answer
and after that what you do in the next step
you score
that answer is true or false
answer is right or wrong
you keep that in the score
and then you store that score somewhere
so basically you are
appending in a list
you did this 8000 times
and once the loop is over
now you have this results
big list
in which every question has
after the loop is over
you extract the mean
so that you can know
what is the score on this data set
simple
i guess you are understanding
this is how you do
evaluation using a benchmark
at least in simple ones you have to do this
in more complex
benchmarks
i will give you an example of them
but in basic ones you have to do this
in simple words
you get a list
prepare a prompt around it
you put all the settings correctly
call the model
model sends you the answer
extract the answer from it
score it
and store it somewhere
and you did this in the loop
till all the questions got exhausted
all the questions are done
the loop is over
you have a big list
in which you have the score of every question
this is how evaluation is done
using a benchmark
now the interesting thing is
after seeing this
at least after seeing this process
you feel that this is a very simple thing
you have to run the loop
i will do it easily
you feel that the evaluation process
is simple
you have to take a question every time
send it to the model
check the answer
and do this for every question
when you do this
when you write the code
this whole code
is a pseudo code
but when you write a proper code
you will realize that it is not that straight forward
first of all
when you have to extract the right answer
this is the answer
is 72
72 in words
you have to write some extra code in it
exact scoring
mechanism
according to the benchmark paper
you have to write a different code
you are sending so many questions
to the LLM
you have to put some batching strategy on it
you have to write a different code
sometimes if an API call fails in between
how to retry
you have to write the code separately
if there are rate limits
you have to write the code to handle it separately
so basically you would realize
that the work is to run the loop
to run a reliable loop
at the scale of 8000-10000 LLM calls
you need a lot more
engineering around this
so generally what people do
is that they don't write the whole code
by themselves
there are libraries for this
like one library is yours
LM
evaluation
harness
so basically the side
where the whole plumbing code is being written
and all the additional things
that are being handled
we give it a term
we call it eval harness
eval harness
is basically
you run model
evaluations
sorry I said it wrong
eval harness is a piece of code
that you write
in order to execute
model evaluation
and you don't do this by yourself
there are built in libraries
not built in libraries
there are libraries with which you can do all this
I will show you a sample code
so this is a very famous library
LM evaluation harness
inspect is a famous library
helm is a famous library
the work of these libraries is
with their help you
simply test your LLM
on any benchmark
you don't need to write a lot of code
if you don't do this
then you have to write all this plumbing code
which is hectic
and may not be standardized
so once you do evaluation
then some result comes and once you do evaluation
then some other result comes
so because of the arrival of libraries
because of the arrival of eval harness
the whole work has become a little easier
so if we talk in nutshell
here the analogy is written very well
that you consider the benchmark
as an exam paper
and this evaluation harness
which I am talking about
you consider it as an administration
which conducts the entire exam
which handles everything else
on your behalf
so you don't have to do much
I will show you a quick code
example of this
see this
for this I
I will need my key
just one second
don't worry
I have done this
openai api
I will delete it
so the first thing that you need to do is
you need to install this library
LLM eval
so I have installed this
after that
it will tell me
in this code that openai
because the model that I am testing here
is openai's model
now you can test any other model here
you can test any model from the logging phase
this library gives you this feature
we are basically using this library
we are using this library
this is a very famous library
if you search you will see
LM
this one
this is a very famous company
called eLuther AI
they have built this entire library
with the help of which you can do model evaluations
and inside them
you already get support
you get support
here somewhere there will be a list
of which benchmarks they support
but for now
what I am showing you in the code
we are using GSM 8k
for benchmarking
so here it will ask for my openai key
I will provide it
it is provided
now we just need to write this code
this is not even a code
this is a command
so here
in model arguments
we need to tell which model we want to test
which one we want to evaluate
so we are targeting GPT 5.6
which has just arrived
in num concurrent
5x basically how many concurrent questions
can be handled at a time
max retries we have set here
in tasks you see
we are using GSM 8k benchmark
COT stands for
chain of thought
we are allowing chain of thought
this is a few shot prompting
8 shot prompting
apply chart template limit 20
here we are saying that
do not evaluate 8000 questions
only 20 questions
because we are testing if this setup is working
or not
if we were doing proper evaluation
we would not have put this line
so what would have happened is
there would have been an evaluation of 8000 questions
I don't want to do it
because as much as I know
if I go to evaluate GSM 8k
then
200-300 rupees will go in one evaluation
whereas if I do 20
then my hardly 3-4 rupees will go
or less than that
output path here
our results will be printed
log samples again we want to
log all the results
we are logging all of them
so basically we are running it
and our evaluation process has started
we didn't have to write any code
we didn't have to run any tests
everything is being handled by this command
so basically there is a level of abstraction
because of this eval harness
otherwise we would have to write this code by ourselves
and do a lot of side plumping
we don't have to do that
everything is working on its own
so let's go to evaluation
so basically we are calling
LLM 20 times
because we are evaluating 20 questions
so behind the scene automatically
20 API calls have been done
and look at this result
this is the result
around 90%
so basically 18 out of 20
questions have been correctly
given by our model
and here you can see all the logging is going on
here are the results of GSM 8k
here is the model folder
and here
your
every question
has become a JSON object
dock ID
which question is gone
what is the answer
and you will get all the evaluation
here so you can sit and watch it
for now
there is no point in watching it
I will give you this code
very straight forward
we have logged everything
this is how evaluation is done
because of these libraries
the whole work of evaluation has become so easy
you can run the support of benchmarks
so literally
we have run a small
model evaluation
in front of your eyes
even though it was not that significant
but if I remove the limit from here
if I remove the limit from this place
so we actually
are testing
GPT 5.6
on GSM 8k
the results that will come
can be published
openAI does the same
so
yeah
in this particular section we discussed
what is eval harness
this term is very
easy to understand
so I thought we should cover it
so if you have any question
there is an option in deep eval
deep eval gives you this option
but
deep eval is more application eval side
and there
I saw its code
you have to write more code
this LMEval harness library
is standard
it is used in industry to run benchmarks
you get option in deep eval
if you go to docs
and
if you go to
benchmarks, available benchmarks
you are getting all these benchmarks
so if you go to
GSM 8k
so you can
do this through deep eval
but in deep eval
you have to write
a lot of code to run openAI
whereas
the library that I showed you
you didn't have to write code
it worked by running command
that is why we used that library
deep eval is used for
application evaluation
it gives you that option
that you can
try out your own
fine tuned LMEs
on a benchmark
you don't have many options
in benchmarks
these are mostly saturated benchmarks
ok
there is an option
you can do it with deep eval
but the most premium option is
this one
LMEvaluation harness
that is what we use
some questions are coming
so let's take a break
and handle the questions
the library also has capability
for custom evals
and we have different library for custom evals
I have not run custom evals
practically
as a concept I know how it works
so I have to test it
that LMEvaluation harness
most likely it will give
custom evals because otherwise what's the point
is there any chance
that the same benchmark could produce
different results for the same model
than run on different runs especially
considering that LLMs can generate different
output across multiple
runs
I mean variations will come
but I don't think if you
control the settings
whatever we discussed so far
then there won't be much variation
so in multiple runs I guess
it's overing around the same
number
it shouldn't vary too much
because you are running on 8500
runs daily
after that there shouldn't be much variation
for the same model for the same setting
because you are setting the temperature to zero
so you are killing the creativity of the model
so mostly
similar kind of results
should be seen
we will discuss this
I am telling you
we are reading everything about benchmarks
right
how benchmarks are applied
so it seems like benchmarks are perfect
but it's not like that
there are many problems in benchmarks
we will discuss that, let's read it
we will discuss it later
the point you are saying
we will discuss that
there is a term called contamination
benchmark contamination
is there any question
on this point guys
shall we move forward
ok
now
after reading this
a valid question
may come to your mind
that
benchmarking
since most of the benchmarks are open
open source as in
freely available on the internet
so anyone can do evaluation
anyone can do evaluation of any LLM
so the question is
who all people want to do evaluation
who
will find it important to do evaluation
let's discuss this
who all
the work of evaluation is important
let's discuss this
so primarily
there are three categories of people
who
benchmark LLM
or do model evaluation
first obvious candidate
is Frontier Lab
they will do evaluation
right
Open AI, Anthropic, Google
DeepMind, all of them
obviously
they will do
benchmarking
because it will help them
during the development of the model
right
benchmarking will tell
that the next model they are training
is improving
from the previous version or not
so what they do is
when model training is going on
they will also run the benchmarks
so during the
pre-training stage
they have a fair idea
that our training is going in the right direction
and in between
they can change trajectory also
so there it helps a lot
these benchmarks help a lot in that sense
next in release gating
to decide
whether the new version of the model
is better than the previous one
and should we release it or not
so in release gating also they help you a lot
and lastly in marketing
if their new model
scores very well
in a particular benchmark
then it is a very good
marketing channel for them
you must have heard
that this new model has come
and they have broken the coding benchmark
so every youtuber starts covering it
so marketing is also
bigger than this
now here you have to see one thing carefully
that if you are an AI engineer
and you are selecting
which model you should use
in your application
don't rely on the benchmark numbers
given by the frontier labs
if frontier labs
you should ask
who did this evaluation
if they say
yes we did it ourselves
in our control settings
then you should not trust too much
then it is the same thing
that car's mileage is 25
if you go to the
that is the higher limit
because they create their favorable conditions
in every way
and run the benchmark
and publish its numbers
on top of that
they do cherry picking
what they do is
their model
will show the good scores
and where it is not doing well
so it will look like
the model is very bad
but when you use it in real world
you will see that the results are not that impressive
and this has happened with all of us
that there are a lot of bad models
now let's talk about fable
I used fable
whatever was its hype
I could not match it
I don't know if your experience will be different
but I never felt that
fable was as strong as it was said
that the government banned it
and I never saw
that they said
that behind the scenes
they send queries to opus
so again
you have to be careful
sorry about that
so the first category of people
who benchmark
is
Frontier Labs itself
because for them it is a very important thing
second is there are some third party
evaluators
so you might have seen that
some leader boards exist
such as LM Arena
or some companies exist
whose work is
that by benchmarking different
organizations
they make a ranking score
and list them out
and they have been doing this for a long time
so now people start trusting them
because whenever they
test two different models
a clod model and an open AI model
they will test in the same conditions
so their ranking
is more reliable
so basically these are
independent organizations
whose evaluation is product
so that's how it is
and
how to read their numbers
their numbers are most reliable
you can see
the reports of these leader boards
and these companies
in the most reliable
and trustworthy way
like LM Arena
and
leader board
now this leader board
is reliable
because this is a third party
and this
they have also known
how they have made
this leader board
so this is reliable
so you can
trust them
and the good thing is that they tell you
more things like
how much is your cost and latency
to use these models
many leading labs don't tell you
they will just tell you the benchmark number
they will not tell you how much time or cost it will take
so you get all this from
third party evaluators
so this is the second category of people
who do evaluations and benchmarking
and the last category is basically you guys
who are AI engineering teams
and you have to make LLM based applications
so what they do is
they don't rely on
the frontier labs
or third party evaluators
they simply say
we have tools
publicly available benchmarks
LM evaluation harness
libraries like that
let's run our own evaluation
to see how much is
scoring on a particular benchmark
in our conditions
so you do it
on your level
so basically there are 3 stakeholders
who have to or can do these evaluations
frontier labs, third party evaluators
and companies and AI engineers
so I guess
you understood this
or you are right
these leader boards
they are like IMDB ranking for models
you can take it like that
in the next session I will show you
in more detail
what are the other leader boards
and how do they
do the entire
leader boards
actually
are aggregation of multiple benchmarks
so don't worry
we will cover leader boards in the next class
for now we won't be able to cover leader boards in this class
so yeah
one last topic
let's quickly cover
till now we have read
everything about benchmarks
in this way we have read that
benchmarks are super important
and they help us in knowing
about any particular LLM capability
but it's not like
benchmarks are flawless
perfect
and you always believe in
the information you get from it
in many scenarios
benchmarks are misleading
so you can't blindly trust them
you have to be
very very careful
if you are reading benchmarks
you have to be very very careful
there are 3-4 types of problems in benchmarks
let's discuss them one by one
the first problem is benchmark contamination
what does it mean
it means very simple
many of your benchmarks
MMLU, GSM 8
and many more
they are mostly
public benchmarks
what does it mean to have a public benchmark
that their research paper
their methodology
and their data set
are all publicly available on the internet
and specially those benchmarks
that came very early in 2021
2022, 2023
their data set
is available on the internet
for a long time
now imagine that recently 6 months ago
OpenAI
trained 5.6
so
in this
they scraped the most recent
internet data
so there is a good chance
that when you are
scrapping the internet data
and putting it in pre-training
then the data set
of this public benchmark
data set means questions and their correct answers
also become
a part of this model's pre-training
now if he has seen
all 8000-8500 questions and answers
then in future
when you ask him
to tell you the answer to this question
there is no guarantee that he is thinking
or he has memorized
so that is why
for a long time
your big models
who have done pre-training on a big data set
for them these benchmarks are
contaminated because they already know the answer
because they became a part of their training data
so this is a big problem
specially with public
benchmarks so the solution
is to use private
benchmarks
there are many private benchmarks
we will discuss in the next class
or use dynamic benchmarks
these are like static benchmarks
once the data set
published in research
is the same data set since last 5 years
but there are certain dynamic benchmarks as well
where on a daily basis
or in a particular window
the data set keeps updating
so those types of data sets
can be used
but benchmark contamination is a proper thing
second
there is one more thing
benchmark saturation
benchmark saturation is a process
where a benchmark
comes in the picture
let's say in 2021
so now this is new
and no model has
any idea about this benchmark
no one has seen it
so on these questions
most of the times your models
poorly perform
25% score or 36% score
all the models are doing this
but over time
the benchmark is static
there are no changes in this
but your models are improving
every 6 months
so their performance
over these questions improve over time
so you will see that
new model starts performing better
last generation of models
were at 36%
now they are at 50%
and then 70%
over time your models
start doing over 90-95%
and all the models cluster at the same place
so there is no difference in score
between them
opus 9.5
your most recent model
is at 95%
gpt 5.6 is at 94%
google gemini is at 92%
so basically there are many clustering
at the same place
this is called benchmark saturation
this means that this benchmark
is no longer useful
you can't differentiate the models
because if all have the same marks
then it will be called exam
then how will you know
who is good and who is bad
in that case the benchmark is saturated
it is removed
and then a new benchmark is brought
and then the industry starts working on that
so this example of gsm 8k
this is a
saturated benchmark
it is not used now
everyone gets 94-97%
I said your MMLU
that is a saturated benchmark
sui bench is also saturated
so mostly there is a life cycle
of benchmarks
all the models are difficult
then gradually the models improve
everyone starts scoring well
then your benchmark is saturated
then it is retired
then replaced with a new benchmark
that is how the benchmarking process is done
after that
this is also a problem of configuration gaming
configuration gaming is basically a term
where frontier ai labs
when they benchmark
then they
create a configuration related mess
means they will give their model
the most favorable conditions
and the rival model the default conditions
or
you can think
what was the point
I forgot
but roughly you can think that
the basic idea of configuration gaming is
that the configuration run you are given
you provide the most favorable
conditions
for example
you are benchmarking gsm 8k
and there you
gave your model the tool of python interpreter
so it solved all the mathematical questions
so obviously
the score will be better
so you can mess with the configuration
there are many possibilities
and there is a lot of variation
so be careful
especially what I said
that frontier labs
if they say that they have broken our model
then you should never believe that
because how did you test the model in your house
I don't know
you can do anything
you have your eval harness
what level of reasoning
you have set
what temperature value you have set
I have no idea
what is your latency value
how much cost you are getting
you are simply giving me a number
that 92% came on this benchmark
I don't trust you
and lastly aggregation
the last step of benchmarking
where you have all the questions
which you aggregate from the numbers
there many people play smartly
so the frontier lab can do this
like MMLU
you have 57 questions
of subjects
so it is possible that
a model is scoring well in physics
but in economics
it is scoring very poorly
so now your model provider
will tell you average score
instead of giving you individual scores
and it will not tell you
that our model is not that good in economics
now you had to make
a chatbot based on economics
you saw that MMLU score is good
in 57 subjects
you deployed it
you found out that it is performing very poorly
in economics equations
because its marks were very bad in economics
so again
because it can be hidden
in benchmarks
so you didn't know and then this happened
so these are the 4 major reasons
because of which
you have to take benchmarks with a
pinch of salt
the number which you have thrown on your face
you don't have to believe it
you have to implement your own methodology
and on the basis of that
you have to decide which model
will work and which will not
we will discuss more on that
as much as I wanted to cover
it is not enough
we will discuss more in one session
how to handle score practically
but yeah
roughly that's all we had to cover
yeah
so yeah let me know guys
this whole discussion
I understood
guys
so
did you learn something new? was it interesting?
let's hope
so if you have any questions then ask
that's all we are reading today
so
if you don't have any questions then go
have dinner
if you have any questions then I am here for
5 more minutes
is this session recording?
can't see
okay
okay guys
if you have any questions then ask
otherwise I will close the session
okay
I guess
there are no questions
okay guys
then
in one more session
we will discuss some benchmarks
which are important
which I want to discuss with you
we will do that in next session
and then we will do custom eval
in next session
okay
so yeah
there is a question
there are some specialized models
for specific work
do they go through
same benchmark
Sanjay give an example
otherwise I don't understand
there is a specialized model
say Quen coder
so for coding
it is either
pre-trained or fine tuned
so we will test that
on coding or software related benchmarks
but in these
8 categories only one will fall
if it won't fall in these 8 categories
then you have custom eval
you can run it yourself
so knowing
the benchmarking can help
where we can use
for which purpose we can use the specific model
yeah that's the main
gist of today's
okay like financial
services and law
yeah Sanjay in that case
I think you have to run your own custom eval
if it is very specific to a niche
then you have to run your own custom eval
we will read that
basically the
I have given an example at the beginning of this session
you will bring your data set
and a scoring mechanism
and you will evaluate it
but the idea
is same
I saw your mcp videos
I have question I created mcp
server for expense tracker and added it
to Claude but who is creating
the mcp client I am able to
add it Claude is
doing on your behalf
yeah obviously custom
is in your control
benchmarks are generic
capabilities
high level capabilities
but something very specific
to your application
then you have to rely on your own data
on your own eval
obviously
is it a generic client or it creates
one for each server it creates one
client for each server
it is internally
is there an example where Frontier
lab evaluated a benchmark higher
than third party evaluator I think
it happens very frequently I have not tracked
but I think it happens very frequently
you
understand Frontier labs evaluation
like car companies
are telling their AR AI
mileage and
third party evaluators
are youtubers
who are auto car
motor octane all these
who are actually running on the ground
that you are being told the mileage
ok guys
I will close the session see you in the next session
bye good night
no no now don't talk about all this
I know
good night